matt lafleur the coach of the team
talking about whether or not he needs to
have two plans of approach for the 2021
season depending upon who the
quarterback is here's what leflore had
to say
now we'll we'll have one plan we've kind
of uh pretty much laid that out just
gonna fine-tune some things over the
next few weeks and uh just in terms of
the logistics of our schedule and
whatnot but we've got what we feel is a
pretty good blueprint um in terms of
how to get our guys ready to play
obviously
it is a little bit different this year
uh in terms of the number of preseason
games and then you compare it to last
year so you're kind of leaning back on
the 2019 season
so but you know we feel confident with
what we what we'll have in place with
the guys and
you know we'll look forward to getting
them back july 27th
they wrapped their off-season program
yesterday they did kind of a weird thing
at the end they did their mandatory mini
camp last week this week they had a
scaled-down set of otas that's leflore
meeting the media on the way out the
door
as we all now wait to see
when if whether
whenever however aaron rodgers is going
to be back what's been your
overall thought on this whole thing that
rogers first brought up after they lost
to the bucks and then two days later he
tried to act like it was no big deal and
then the day of the draft the day the
draft began it all blew up and it stayed
blown up ever since then what's been
your thought as to all of what's gone on
with rogers since their season ended my
thought has been pretty consistent
throughout it's that aaron rodgers
happiness is paramount in my mind i want
him to be happy i want him to enjoy his
life and it seems to me like green bay
is a toxic place for him no but
seriously uh it's it's so clear that
it's just timelines got screwed up here
right like you we all we all know
exactly what happened aaron rodgers had
a uh not great year a couple years ago
the last year for mike mccarthy
the packers said okay this guy is in his
mid to late 30s
we as an organization which i'm going to
give the packers credit this is why the
packers are consistently good is that
they are always thinking to the future
they are always saying hey we're not
going to mortgage everything right now
we're gonna try to keep this going
consistently throughout uh and then
aaron rodgers played out of his mind and
aaron rodgers went to back-to-back nfc
championship games and aaron rodgers won
the mvp and their timeline got screwed
up because i think they were fully ready
to move on from aaron rodgers after this
coming year and that's why they drafted
jordan love and that probably made aaron
rodgers upset and the timelines got
screwed up because aaron rodgers
outplayed their expectations for him at
his point in his career and now they're
stuck with a situation which i don't
really understand how it gets fixed i i
mean mike you you know a lot more about
the inner workings
and you hear a lot more
but
i i if you had to if you had to say hey
you have to pick one or the other like
you have to pick you have to make a
decision i still think aaron rodgers is
a packer weak one because i don't know
how this gets fixed if both sides just
say like we're not moving at all because
i don't think aaron riders wants to
retire but it doesn't feel like a
relationship that is built to last here
no absolutely not and
i think the key was 2019 even though
they went 13-3 they may have seen some
signs
that cause them to think okay eventually
father time is going to win as to him as
it will as to every other quarterback we
need to be prepared we need to be ready
they would say they didn't go into the
2020 draft with a plan
to get a quarterback it just kind of
unfolded that way they wanted justin
jefferson didn't get him the vikings did
they wanted branded iuk they didn't get
him the 49ers jumped the line to get
ayuk and then they kind of freaked out
after the 49ers took ayuk at 25 they
freaked out and moved up to 26 to get
jordan love instead of trying to get a
receiver they had a team that was super
bowl ready or close to it and this kind
of threw the curve ball
at everyone's head as we tried to figure
out what in the hell is going on and one
thing rogers said
earlier in
the off-season i think it was with kenny
mayne he's spoken a few times but in the
appearance on maine's final sports
center
the notion that
rogers performance in 2020 threw a
wrench into their plans i think rogers
believed they were going to make the
switch after 2020
but he has the great season they go back
to the nfc championship they get so
close to winning i think they felt
compelled that they had to keep him
around for another year especially when
you consider jordan love didn't have a
preseason to develop he got limited reps
never dressed for a game i think they're
nervous about the prospect of going
forward with jordan love this year they
want aaron rodgers for one more year
unless deep down i kind of wonder
whether mark murphy does
i think mark murphy would kind of like
it if he didn't show up and they get 35
million back and then they trade him
next year he doesn't go somewhere else
and make them look bad this year but
they don't have to deal with them this
year i think murphy hopes he doesn't
show but i agree with you when it's time
to show he's going to because what's he
got four years left you're gonna give up
25 of your remaining career just because
you don't like the guy who runs the team
you like your coaches you like your
teammates you like the fans you love
green bay you're not going to show up
because there's one or two guys that you
don't like i don't buy that but with all
that said and i agree with everything
you said aaron rodgers is the one guy
that you could actually see that
happening with because he does feel like
uh someone who takes these things
personally that says when you know when
he feels he wore the i'm offended shirt
earlier this week on a uh i think it was
a zoom call before the match their play
of their golf match
he he clearly is that type of
personality i'm not saying that's right
or wrong i'm saying that that's just
what you're dealing with is a guy
who is has strong opinions and if he
feels slighted he's going to say it and
he's going to act the way that a
slighted person acts i the whole thing
is fascinating and obviously removing
myself from the fact that i just want
aaron rodgers out of the nfc north so
i've been uh commenting on all his
instagram posts and basically being like
you look so happy you should stay in
hawaii forever this is an interesting
transition phase though for the nfl in
general because you saw it with russell
wilson a little bit this offseason where
the like player empowerment and
franchises having to adjust to their
franchise quarterbacks like this is
going to start happening a little bit
more
and
he looks incredibly happy he's i mean
this is he's living his best life i love
this for aaron rodgers the way he's able
to enjoy his offseason but my point my
greater point is this
the uh player like empowerment you've
seen it a lot in the nba i think it's
kind of coming now to the nfl and it's
it's fascinating to watch because the
nfl is uh you know as a league where
there's 53 guys and and
and it's harder to build a roster and
you can't say okay this one guy gets all
the preferential treatment but
aaron rodgers russell wilson patrick
mahomes tom brady some of these guys
deserve it and i think aaron rodgers
deep down knows like his one trump card
in all of this
he knows he's been there he's played
these games he's been in this locker
room he's been in this organization he
knows how much aaron rodgers the talent
basically hides the lack of talent
around the roster and makes up for all
these things and he knows what the
packers product is going to look like
without him under center and it's not
pretty like aaron rodgers you might want
to say he's mercurial he's you know what
is a complicated fellow all these things
i hate him but if you if you're gonna
sit here and say he's not
one of if not the best quarterback
playing right now like you're crazy
that's what the guy does you he makes
everyone so much better and he makes
everyone's job so much easier that maybe
sometimes you should put up with a
little bit from him and maybe sometimes
you should bend a little bit and be a
little more flexible and not have this
hard-line stance where it's organization
over everything i don't know the right
answer i just know that if i were a gm i
would do everything to keep a guy like
aaron rodgers happy so that we don't get
to this spot
you know i don't know if you and i have
talked about this if we have it hasn't
been recent but i'm a firm believer that
for the true franchise quarterbacks and
every team wants its starting
quarterback to to essentially be
a member of management among the
employees they want the quarterback to
set the tone get there early stay there
late study film hold teammates
accountable be the one who sends the
message that comes from the coaching
staff for the front office and helps get
the guys on board with it
if that's how you view your quarterback
and i think that's how you need to take
advantage of his position of inherent
leadership when it's time to have the
management meeting you can't slam the
door in his face right you can't tell
him
you you just work here that's what the
packers have consistently done to aaron
rodgers that's what the seahawks
reportedly did to russell wilson last
year when he was trying to get them to
fix their offense on the fly and when
you see tom brady getting everything he
wants from the tampa bay buccaneers and
he's driving the bus
he's in charge and they they have no
qualms about it bruce aaron's throwing
in the keys i think that's caused these
other quarterbacks
to say what the hell
what we see and it worked they let brady
run the show and it worked why don't we
have a little more say well it was let's
let's hold on one second with the brady
thing that roster was really good and it
wasn't tom brady building that roster
it is no no but i don't get
there and he got antonio brown there and
he got everything he wanted yes yes
absolutely and i do think the bucks are
kind of needling it to the packers a
little bit with all these reports about
how he's he's deciding the roster and
he's helping with wide receivers i think
the list to be totally honest mike and i
know there'll be people who will push
back on this when you're talking true
true franchise quarterbacks the list
right now of guys that we're saying that
the management should do everything to
keep happy is three it's tom brady it's
aaron rodgers it's patrick mahomes i
wouldn't even put russell wilson in that
list russell wilson is a fantastic
talent i don't think that russell wilson
elevates their entire roster to a level
where it's like he can fix everything
with his play
and tom brady's more on reputation pat
from home's aaron rodgers are more on
play right now where
they if you if you make a mistake in
your roster building they can fix it by
being that special and if that's the
case guess what if you're the gm you got
to look at him aaron rodgers or patrick
from home and say he makes my job easier
he makes me look good i want to make
sure that he is happy and everything is
working here because i will get more
money and again at the end of the day we
know this mike
the nfl is a very selfish league when it
comes to all of these front offices
organizations everyone's looking out for
themselves that's the part i don't
understand if you're the gm of the
packers looking out for yourself here
would be to keep aaron rodgers happy and
keep him playing for the green bay
packers
on russell wilson i agree with you to a
point i i think that he's not that guy
like mahomes brady and rogers because
they don't let him be that guy and i
think that's one of the pressure points
he wants to be mahomes he wants to have
that same
whether or not he's able to pull it off
we don't know but he wants the offense
to run through him and there's the
tension between him and pete carroll who
wants to play defense and run the ball
and they were letting russ cook last
year until
the defenses caught up with what they
had changed with their offense and they
weren't able to bust through it and pete
carroll took the whole team back into a
shell and that's how it went down the
stretch i'll put deshaun watson close to
that category too though because the
texans have a crap roster around him and
he had a hell of a year last year and
this all started with watson and i know
it got derailed with the off-field
issues but this all started because why
they're looking for a coach looking for
a gm they ask for his input he says hey
interview eric b enemy they don't at
first interview robert sala they don't
and it gets back to that whole thing you
either work here or you're part of
management and too many of these teams
have a you just work here attitude with
guys that they shouldn't
uh fair point on deshaun watson um who
who knows what's gonna happen with the
rest of this year you know where is
what's gonna happen with the texas i
don't even i don't even think about the
texans every now and then someone brings
them up i'm like oh yeah that's still a
franchise uh russell wilson it's been so
long since i've been on that
and i love russell i love watching
russell wilson but i'm i'm firmly in the
camp that
we as like the media
don't really criticize russell wilson
enough for some of these playoff losses
and some of these later season collapses
and i i don't know i just think the
shine's a little off for me with russell
wilson he's still i would take him the
happiest i was in the off season before
justin fields got drafted was the day
and a half that russell wilson was a
fake bear i he's a phenomenal talent i'm
not saying he's not a top five top 10
quarterback i'm just saying there's a
distinct distinct difference
in aaron rodgers and patrick holmes and
russell wilson in my mind
i did wonder how close they came to
contacting the family of bronco nagurski
to see if they would consent to number
three being unretired so that russell
wilson could wear it there was that
period of time where it looked they were
going to do it but why why because
wilson wants to be with nagi because
naggy was in kansas city for the first
year of patrick holmes before he played
but he was there when mahomes was a
rookie and was learning and the idea was
the thinking is
matt nagy would be like andy reid and
say
we're going gonna make this all work
through you i think that was the
attraction to chicago why are you
shaking your head because if if russell
wilson's decision making is that matt
nagy could be like andy reid i don't
want him on the pitch because that's not
the correct decision
that's terrible you have to question
everything he thinks if that was what he
was thinking
uh appearing next uh on pardon my take
matt maggie bears coach i'd love to have
someone i would be not you know me i
don't just i wouldn't be mean but i
would say hey man like there are times
when the moment is too big for you
so i'm sure i think we're talking about
him next which i have some criticisms
for him
we will be talking about the about the
bears in the next segment but with
rogers look i
i think this does end with him showing
up and i really do think that deep down
mark murphy would prefer
that he didn't because it this is the
perfect transition year because if he
doesn't show up they can blame him
first of all he's under contract for
three more years and i think you know
the fans will tend to line up behind the
laundry like they always do it drives me
crazy but when the fans side with the
billionaires over the millionaires of
course in green bay there's no
billionaire to get behind you really are
getting behind the laundry and you're a
part owner if you've got that 200
piece of paper that you hang on the wall
in your basement because you have one
share of green bay packers stock so it's
easier to get behind the team and i
think that's what murphy wants
he doesn't show up the fans line up
behind the team
rogers is the bad guy like farve was in
2008 even though they didn't want farv
there either jordan love gets a year
where he goes out and whatever happens
happens and we don't have to worry about
rogers as a bronco or a raider or with
some other team ending up in the super
bowl and we get 35 million back between
salary and bonuses and cap space that
can be used
on other positions with the team and
then by 2022 we trade him we get three
three first round picks for him and we
move on with our new organization post
rogers i think for everything you just
laid out it it would work uh and
obviously you know fans your right would
get behind the laundry i think you'd
have to get the picks before this season
i think you'd want to trade him before
this season and then it's uh because
then it is that clean move on like what
you're saying right now makes sense like
the hey it's it's it's in the it's in
the rear view we've moved on if aaron
rodgers doesn't show up and doesn't play
this year and he's not traded it you
know how that works it's a conversation
the entire season and if jordan loves
starts poorly it's like well where's
aaron rodgers can we bring him back so i
think you'd want for for what you just
said what you just laid out to actually
work it needs to be a clean he's no
longer a green bay packer he is a denver
bronco or someone else these are the
picks we have
this is what we're planning on doing
going forward we'll you know see a week
one we'll pack the place and everyone
will buy their
their stupid cheese heads
i like the idea of trading him as late
as possible so that he can't show up in
denver
and take them to the super bowl and
really you put him in denver
with the chiefs and mahomes in the same
division
gonna be a little bit more difficult
than it would be in another place for
him to have a great season i mean if
brady had gone to the chargers or the
raiders of the broncos last year i don't
know that you guarantee he's going to
make it to the super bowl because he's
got to deal with mahomes in his own
division but well but they you know they
still they still didn't win the division
in the nfc south and got hot and won the
super bowl so i won't put anything past
brady but as it relates to the timing
here here's my concern from the packers
standpoint
if you trade him between now and week
one
you're going to get less
than if you wait until after the season
because the 2021 draft obviously come
and gone you're going to get draft picks
in 22 either way if you trade them now
if you trade them in march i just think
if you wait till march you're going to
have 10 teams that may come to the table
right now where's your leverage to get
the best possible deal you got the
broncos and maybe the raiders although
they all the stuff we're hearing about
derek carr and john gruden and uh maybe
the raiders wouldn't be interested maybe
they want to let it ride with derek carr
again so if you've got one team
who's trying to get the guy you're not
going to get the same deal you could get
in march when we've gone through another
season of football and teams have
decided yeah our guy sucks we gotta find
somebody else and they're gonna they're
gonna show up for the auction for the
aaron rodgers contract i think the
leverage still is with the broncos is
like you know this is your magic bullet
like this is the the the john if you
called up john elway and you're like hey
last few years haven't been so fun have
they well guess what i give you you know
we do this trade
you're back you're back to legendary
status team building everything like
that roster is ready to go vic fangio
will not bother aaron rodgers he will
just run the defense and not bother like
that team
they can compete with anyone and that's
the it is it is basically just taking
that magic bullet like that you you
agree with that though mike like if
you're john elway i don't care about
leverage if someone calls you up if the
green bay packers call you up and say
hey john
like it has it has not been fun people
have questioned you your your legacy in
denver is starting to get a little iffy
here if you still can't figure out
quarterbacks guess what can fix all of
that aaron rodgers it's basically the
flex seal you're just there's a big hole
water coming out and you slap aaron
rodgers on it and everything's fixed in
denver that's the that's the one
seal now
yeah you know the like seal now you know
you know the commercial seal when the
guy there's a big cylinder of water he's
like boom
that's aaron rodgers that is
let me just say this though when the
time comes to talk to the denver broncos
and and it's been a while since we
talked i don't know you've been away
yeah john elway don't work here no more
you don't shine shoes no more oh yeah
okay mike he bought that he got fired
yes he got fired into it
himself yeah he promoted himself
no he's he's he's out george payton's
the guy you got to call now which is
fine because peyton is in minnesota all
those years he knows what rogers can do
fangio was with the bears he knows the
one concern i have about the broncos is
this
fangio isn't going to bother him because
fangio's the defensive guy pat sherman
is the offensive coordinator pat shurmur
is so tightly wound that he's had mike
holmgren
one of the most tightly wound and
profane coaches of the past 25 years
advise him
to lighten up francis that's how tightly
wound patch sure fire patch summer
oh yeah yeah
but and just let aaron rodgers hand pick
whoever comes in or just let aaron
rodgers run the offense like tom brady
does in in although that's not the truth
uh
i i
i i can't rule out anything at this
point because i i'm having a hard time
really
reading the tea leaves here and aaron
rodgers likes that i'm a firm believer
this whole beautiful mystery thing is
something he's concocted it's something
he feeds it's something he wants he is
the classic pro athlete or slash
celebrity
that wants to be the center of attention
but wants to reserve the right to be
upset when everyone pays attention to
him do you agree with that yeah
absolutely he's a uh complicated fella
which really i love that quote because
it's essentially he's a jerk that's all
you're saying if you ask if someone
asked me how's mike floria i wouldn't be
like well he's kind of complicated like
no he's a good guy you know terrible
lawyer good guy but like that that would
be what i would say yes
that's what i would say but but here was
the kicker here's the kicker too
and sims caught this
mark murphy not only said he's a
complicated fella
he said he's a complicated fella and
i'll leave it at that
right which is which is the twist of the
knife right but you know it's like i'm
gonna stop there before i really get
myself into trouble bearing my soul in
what i believe is to this individual i i
can't imagine saying answering like he's
a complicated fella and having that be a
good thing
ever
yeah well and he likes he likes to be
complicated and and that's that's the
thing
they've dealt with this guy
since 2005. now pre-farve
retirement
they didn't have to deal with them once
he became the starter they had to deal
with him and my guess is they've
tolerated a lot over the years from
aaron rodgers because he's so damn good
it's kind of like
a miniature version of antonio brown in
pittsburgh because there's no reason to
believe that rogers has been as over the
top diva-ish as brown was in pittsburgh
but
mike tomlin dealt with it quietly we
didn't know about it from 2010 through
2018. then once tomlin decided you know
what brown's not the guy he used to be
and i've had a decade it is i had a
belly full of antonio brown see you
later i kind of feel like there's a
little bit of that going on with the
packers not nearly to the same extent
but just like you know this this guy's
been keeping us on our toes since 2008.
and it'd be kind of nice to go back to
having a quarterback that we don't have
to tiptoe around all the time yeah and
it blows up the entire facade i mean
football is the one sport where they
love to cling to the idea that no one's
bigger than the team and that everyone
gets treated the same and you know bill
belichick won all those super bowls
because he treated tom brady just like
the 53rd guy on the roster well guess
what time has changed a little bit and
when you have talent that is way better
than everyone else at that position you
do change how you deal with him and i
i'd push back on the bill belichick
thing i bet you he doesn't treat
everyone exactly the same if you read
any of the stories about lawrence taylor
when he was dominating for the giants he
had a different set of rules than
everyone else on the roster and that's
just the reality of pro sports so i
think when it gets like when the curtain
gets pulled back and it's like hey wait
are the packers really not treating
aaron rod like that's that's on the
packers to me because the in in pro
sports in the nfl if you have a guy who
deserves to be treated differently
because he's so good you treat him
differently and you suck it up and
that's just what you do
i agree but once the slippage begins
you can't wait
to not have to treat that guy
differently anymore that there's a price
to be paid for getting different
treatment once you start to slip they're
done that's it we've been dealing with
this too long we're not going to deal
with it anymore yeah we were willing to
deal with it when you were dominant
you're not dominant anymore
we're gonna we're gonna roll the dice
with a guy that doesn't make us have a
separate set of rules that doesn't
constantly create stress for the
organization because we got to worry
about what's aaron going to think of
this what's aaron going to think of that
i mean they knew damn well what they
were doing when they pulled the pin on
that grenade and he can say it's not
about jordan love and jordan loves just
i feel bad for jordan love jordan love
is the only guy in all of this who has
zero blame
and can't and is just caught in the
middle of it even even matt leflore he
took that job matt laflore is caught in
the middle of it but he had to know when
he walked through the door i may be
stepping into a bit of a mess here in
the final years of aaron rodgers career
and whatever tension there may be with
the front office
jordan love got drafted into it he had
no choice whatsoever and you know at
some point they need to be thinking
about doing right by him
yeah well i have this idea
um that they should do away with the
drafts and players should get to pick
their own teams yes yes and now you're
trolling me
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports